hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry and
we're gonna watch the trailer for
Expendables 3 he's at the Expendables or
Expendables I thought it was the
Expendables 3 okay so it has to be the
I'm Society for Mel Gibson again is he
in it
yeah he's the villain again oh yeah
right I always said man Mel Gibson
starts playing villains he'll make a
comeback and machete kills was a huge
hit
yeah I wish it I wish it was I wish I
should have been taking time City yeah
all right here we go
only use me to prove for appropriate
audiences pretty much make sure
appropriate audiences there's a sweet
movie it's kind
I hope the horror movie looks like this
looks like the outro very cool okay so
that doesn't looks all the way real yeah
there we go
dude why are they like dancers as to me
names me where's Gibson was I there
don't [ __ ] you put them in the titles
well that's a pretty cool teaser yeah I
mean you know it's it's simple but it
gets the point across
yeah I gotta be excited it's like
everyone's in this movie this looks
badass
all right oh there's a ton of them all
it turns out it's pretty cool to see all
of them on this on the screen together
yeah I kinda wanna go back and read the
names cuz I'm not sure who everybody is
yeah as long as Terry Crews I'm just
pissed off the input Mel Gibson's name
on it but they [ __ ] have him there
he's evil
well who cares if he's an anti-semite
who just [ __ ] loves to abuse what's
so [ __ ] up [ __ ] Bruce Willis backed
out of this [ __ ] I know wasn't it for he
wanted 1 million more extra dollars
because he means yeah he really needs
that much he's really struggling to get
high-profile work I got the mortgage to
pay this month ok yeah like and I am a
gambling addict knows if I will be in
another very large blockbuster film
anytime soon
forget about the franchise I'm involved
with as well as well